hi I'm Nicolas be with reason and today
we are talking on our audio podcast with
Glenn Reynolds he is a professor of law
at the University of Tennessee and is
better known to everywhere over the
world as the founder and proprietor of
insta pundit comm one of the first
biggest and still best aggregator sites
of commentary links and you name it
Glenn thanks for joining us thank you
for having me so you are in the news
recently rather than talking about the
news you actually created news in North
Carolina a few days ago when protesters
pissed off about Keith Scott stormed an
interstate a local TV station WBTV
tweeted live now protesters on I 277
stopping traffic and surrounding
vehicles avoid watch live you retweeted
that with the three line word run them
down what happened next well it should
be known that's it was against the
context of a whole lot of reports of
violence and rioting not just protesting
in this event um and I guess that's what
set me off with that tweet so honestly
nothing happened right away i tweeted
that it was 851 p.m. at night read my
book went to bed got up the next morning
open my email and people are like why
are you banned on twitter and i was like
i have no idea and it actually took me a
while to figure out what had happened
but over the night that while i slept
peacefully it had somehow exploded i
think a bunch of lefty sites bombarded
twitter and i'm still honestly not sure
whether I was just automatically
suspended by a bot because enough people
reported abuse or spam or whatever or
whether there was human judgment
involved so before we get to that
question or whether or not we can answer
it what what did it feel like I mean as
somebody who obviously you have a life
in meatspace
I know you know who I've seen the
pictures I've met you in real life and
all of that but what it you know was
there an emotional impact to suddenly
you know being cut off from Twitter you
know it was mostly puzzlement initially
and of course one of the problems is
when when people don't like something
you say on Twitter and they get you
suspended
you can't respond you've been not only
silenced but sort of neutralized so once
I figured out what was going on which I
actually found out from a post on twitch
I posted something on my blog which
basically said look I wouldn't say ran
down peaceful innocent protesters I was
saying drive through these blocks of
people who look like they're trying to
kill you and which I saw was a fairly
crucial difference you know and that was
that that was what I put on my blog but
then I had had to fiddle with Twitter
eventually I have found an email from
them that said if I click on a link and
followed some instructions I get my
account restored which I did they
required me to delete the tweet so as
soon as they got back up I put up a link
to twitchy that preserve the tweet so
nobody would think I was trying to hide
stuff and then it was just a matter of
dealing with all of the anger that that
stirred up and the you know
misinterpretations or so talk a little
bit about that because I and I you know
as a longtime reader and I think
somewhere I've posted you were involved
there I quoted you actually one of the
very first things I wrote for reason a
short piece about the Lopez decision
going back to what would it be 95 Cato
back in 94 so but in any case heed I
wrote a defense of your free speech what
was your intention and saying run them
down because Twitter when you look at
the Terms of Use they say you know
basically any incitement to violence and
and a variety of other things is grounds
for being banned or suspended what were
you intending and and how was it
misconstrued if it was misconstrued I
wasn't intending enough to be honest I
mean what was really happening is I was
long in the couch with my phone
retweeting stuff and occasionally
commenting on it and if I had thought
about that for five seconds or even
three I would have said what I meant in
a way that wasn't so exciting but I just
didn't and you know that's one of the
dangers of Twitter and I've always been
aware of it and you know I have over
five hundred eighty thousand tweets and
I guess statistically the odds just
caught up with me right and this is the
first time the
you've been you've been suspended or
blocked so what what was your what if
you had taken you know more than three
words to what what was your intention or
what was the message that you would have
I would have sent something like this is
awful don't stop for these people it's
too dangerous you know I might I might
have said you know run them down if you
have to to get away but I wouldn't have
said it in a way that made people think
or in some cases I suspect pretend to
think that I was saying target these
people just because you know you can do
you and there were reports of cars being
kind of hit and vandalized her
windshield windshield smashed that you
know there was a woman on the phone with
the local TV station surrounds a truck
driver whose truck was being looted and
was scared for her life she said now you
know what's interesting is that as a law
professor and as somebody of libertarian
bent of mind and you would you I mean
just as a side note do you consider
yourself libertarian conservative do you
use a different descriptor that fits you
best
I I consider myself a libertarian I mean
there are so many different flavors of
libertarianism that the most important
thing you do as soon as you consider
yourself a libertarian is announce that
nobody else is a real libertarian like
you that's wrong but but that said yes
you know that means that I'm a believer
in as minimal a government as we can get
and you know I sort of when I talk about
my policy preferences sometimes people
are surprised but I have to explain to
them that you know there's sort of the
theory of the second best there was the
situation I would have if I controlled
everything and there's the incremental
policy thing I would do next that I hope
will make things better but yeah I'm
certainly not a conservative I mean you
know that well one of the things I was
going to bring up is that you have been
critical and I know that you've linked
certainly to a lot of reasoned stuff and
Radley Balko both when he was a Cato
when he was at Reason when he was at the
Huffington Post
now at the Washington Post talking about
the militarization of police and police
abuse you have issues about cert the
surveillance date and things like that
and I'm not saying that you're a super
you know you're totally in on any kind
of negativity towards law enforcement by
any stretch but you know where where do
you see the country going with
these questions about black lives matter
protests or more broadly there is a real
concerted and heartfelt and I think
meaningful pushback against some of the
ways in which police I have been doing
business for decades now well you know
the biggest problem with the police is
not that they shoot people sometimes
because that's inevitable with their job
it's not even that they shoot the wrong
people sometimes because that's kind of
also inevitable over time the real
problem the police is that they are
perceived and I think it's a correct
perception not to be accountable when
they shoot the wrong person for the
wrong reasons and it's not only that I
mean they're not perceived not to be
accountable for a wide variety of
misdeeds and they're perceived that way
because in fact they get away with a lot
you know and what what is what's driving
that why do why do police get away I
mean and you know I know we've run
stories about this I know you've written
stuff about it you're also besides being
the proprietor of insta pundit comm you
are a regular contributor to USA Today
where you write a weekly column that is
pretty wonderful I try never to miss it
but why do cops get away with stuff that
you or I would not get away with well a
couple of reasons that one is they as
they there's sort of a paramilitary
organization which you know means that
camaraderie at Asprey decor are a big
part of what they do and that basically
boils down in real life to covering for
your buddy
and since cops typically control the
initial reporting and gathering of
evidence in an event that happens it's
pretty easy for them to protect each
other that way then second of all
prosecutors depend heavily on the cops
to do their job and they know that
unless a case is truly egregious the
police will be angry if they prosecute a
police officer also they're inclined not
to and then of course jurors tend to be
pretty sympathetic to cops too so even
if they do prosecute them the cop has a
pretty good chance of walking and on top
of that they're usually unionized and so
they have a lot of political protections
so that that's a pretty good recipe for
getting out of jail free most of the
time to bring it back to Twitter and
free speech now Twitter and you know and
you're you're a libertarian of some sort
of flavor I think I'm a hot fudge sundae
pop-tarts
look at Aaron and I won't low carb
libertarian okay yes so you're you're a
paleo not a paleo libertarian maybe like
a diet libertarian but yeah
what do you does Twitter have the right
to ban people that it says you know what
for whatever reason you know I don't
like your speech get the hell off of my
platform yeah generally speaking sure
that a private company they're not bound
by the Constitution now one thing that's
a little tricky about Twitter is that
they're a publicly traded company and
they tell their investors as well as
their customers that they don't censor
but off a lot of people who paid close
attention to what they do conclude that
in fact they they come down much harder
on people on on the right run a broad
line construed right yeah yeah well the
non left I guess you could say you get
you get away with a lot more if you're
on the left and well you know a big you
know a recent kind of cause related to
that was Milo you nah police the
Breitbart editor alt right kind of
figure was Breitbart London or Breitbart
tack or both I'm not sure yeah and aus
bite mark he was he was suspended or
banned permanently for life after
tweeting various things at an actress
and that that led to a lot of heaping
amounts of racial abuse on on a black
woman do you know do you think is that
good is that bad
should Twitter be more wide open and
letting people Duke it out they do have
a series of type you know of tools that
allow people to block or to avoid saying
things they don't want to see is that
enough or should they be policing all
right so I think they should do less
policing you'd give people more tools to
protect against you know being troubled
and threatened in touch that would
certainly be my privates the other
problem that makes it a little rougher
is and this is not just Twitter this is
of all the social media step it's all
kind of a semi monopoly I mean it's a
small number of companies that really
control almost all social media and they
all kind of leave
I mean Facebook has been accused and I
think again quite credibly of having a
lot of political buyers and they've done
experiments that suggest that they could
swing an election by manipulating their
flow of news and views and you know at
some level you you say that's just
private enterprise they could do what
they want but at another level it's it's
a it's a little more troubling when they
are kind of a monopoly and they're
politically in the tank with an
administration that is doing them a lot
of favors so what are the favors at end
let's let's let's fixate on this a
little bit because it is an interesting
question especially from a libertarian
perspective you know Twitter does not
have I mean if to the if they have great
market share they don't have a monopoly
on social media on free speech neither
does Facebook even though these are the
you know they're beyond the McDonald's
of you know whatever McDonald's might be
to fast food restaurants or Walmart is
to retail these guys are even bigger
but do they is it I mean you're not
saying that they should be forced to
kind of enforce a Fairness Doctrine or
anything you're you're arguing that it
is for the benefit of public discourse
that they relax a little bit and let
people speak more freely or yeah I
wouldn't I'm a mature affair this
doctrine for social media with Laura
like I would if I figured out what it
was I'm pretty sure I wouldn't be for it
but but I'm not so sure that we aren't
approaching the point where people might
want to think about antitrust and I know
we're past the point where if these were
companies that operated with a slant
toward Republicans everyone would be
calling for antitrust regulation right
away
and talk about the horrible dangers of
this but what they really are is they
are quite demonstrably and there's been
a lot of reporting on this actually in
bed with the Obama administration and
Google people been meeting at the White
House all the time and they're also
being very lightly regulated by the
Obama administration they get breaks on
everything from taxes to immigration and
that really does make you suspicious but
it also looks like they're sort of
slanting stories in a particular
political direction by the same token we
know that Twitter Facebook Google eBay
you know that they have been forced to
or and I don't think it was quite
willingly but they've been forced to
cough up huge amounts of data or to
allow you know kind of vacuum cleaners
on stuff yeah are they I mean is let's
let's to put it slightly differently are
they in bed with the Obama
administration for ideological reasons
or is it that they also realize that the
federal government you know can do
whatever it wants to them and can you
know Microsoft going back 15 years or so
Microsoft had been doing pretty well and
then they got a major antitrust suit
against them that tied them up for years
I mean are they are these guys quaking
in fear are they marching arm and arm
with a kind of liberal or progressive
ideological agenda well that's probably
some of both you know I think with Al
Capone who said you get more with a kind
word and a gun than a kind word alone
yeah and you know what the Mexican drug
lords I think there's some silver or led
you know they will bribe you or they
will kill you so I think I think
coercion and favors kind of go hand in
hand in these kind of things but it's
definitely I think kind of troubling I
mean and I have to say my roots about
this a few months ago when I was
criticizing Twitter and such you know in
the early days of the blogosphere we had
a lot of independent blog site so that
was sort of a drag for some people
because it was relatively hard to set up
your own website even if you had to set
it up a blogger like sites like Facebook
or Twitter make it much easy to just log
on and start putting your views out but
on the other hand now you want somebody
else's platform and they have control
right well let's let's talk a little bit
about that because you know and we are
talking to Glenn Reynolds you know him
both as a University of Tennessee law
professor a USA Today columnist and
perhaps best known as the proprietor the
founder the Internet's insta pundit at
insta pundit comm and this is the reason
audio podcast you can find us at itunes
on soundcloud go to reason.com slash
podcast we also have our SS feeds both
for our audio podcast as well as our
videos talk a bit about that the the
wild west of the internet it was
probably dead by the time you started
insta pundit and I believe August of
2001 are we you know is it that the
internet now and that so you started you
know in saponin is 15 years old are we
so domesticated now is this kind of is
it of mature industry almost where that
early spirit of kind of free speech and
a flame wars and where people would say
the most horrible things and it was kind
of expected like that seems to have been
banished from today's Internet are we in
a kind of corporatized bureaucratized
you know snowflake world yeah yeah I
mean honestly if you want to think about
the role of sort of Twitter management
or whatever it's basically they're like
the HR department for the internet now
and that's not that appealing to me yeah
what do you think here is a question
that I come back to often be and I and I
say this is somebody I've been marking
at reason since 1993 when I joined it
was definitely part of the alternative
media because there was a very big gulf
between sites you know we're based in LA
or yet a part of us is and our
headquarters is there the difference
between reason and the LA Times was
massive nowadays we've had Matt Welch my
colleague co-author on the Declaration
of Independence actually left reason and
worked for the LA Times and then came
back to reason because it was a more
vital institution you know things have
really changed but do you feel like
freedom of speech is simultaneously it
seems that we have more and more ways of
getting our messages out there whether
they're good bad or ugly but there is
also an ever-increasing attempt to
control and regulate speech yeah you
know what what is this just kind of you
know are we Charlotte Holmes and
Professor Moriarty falling over
Reichenbach Falls forever and ever
infinitely or are we winning are we
losing if we're on the side of more
expression rather than less expression
well you know I actually wrote a column
a while back on this and my sort of
tagline was speech is freer but people
are less pretty and and that's sort of
how it is there are lots of ways to get
your message out but the powers that be
our and also honestly a lot of your
fellow citizens they're just a lot more
comfortable about about punishing people
and silencing them you know do you feel
and this is something out you know I'll
be I guess it's not a proprietary secret
for reason but I'm sure you've seen this
a lot in your own traffic you know five
or six years ago I'd say insta pundit
was probably our single biggest traffic
source there one of them you know and
and you're you were have done an
incredible job of aggregating and I
think in the post I wrote defending your
freedom of speech I say you know insta
pundit is the first or second site that
I check every day after reason you know
it's that central but nowadays most of
our traffic referrals come from Facebook
then Twitter is second do you find that
Facebook and Twitter and I suppose you
know we're getting into an area where in
a places like Instagram and snapchat
supposedly have more daily users than
Twitter that you have been displaced as
as a first order aggregator even if your
traffic is still strong and does that
worry you not because the government is
suppressing speech but to kind of go
back to what you were saying these other
bottlenecks or these gatekeeper you know
new gatekeepers are growing up in a
world that was once kind of a big sky
country for whoever showed up yeah well
it system it's my traffic continues to
grow it doesn't go as fast as it in and
those handy early days but it goes up
every year but you know a lot more
people are on Facebook and my own
experience is that Facebook drives a lot
of traffic and Twitter doesn't Drive
that much people I actually somebody was
saying in my comments that he posts
recipes and people never follow the link
to the recipe they just look at the
picture with Facebook sends him a lot of
traffic he says it's just amazing the
difference and that's kind of my
experience but you know yeah I mean
people still suck up to me for traffic
but it is I guess that's in part because
you can't really suck up to Facebook for
traffic you've got to market it out
there somehow you know and if we knew
where to suck up I suspect we'd be doing
that but we are we are talking to Glenn
Reynolds he's the insta pondan and
you reminded me in terms of the traffic
we are you still see people talking
about the insta Lance what happens when
you would get a get an insta pundit link
and I can remember early days that
reason where we would actually have our
server breakdown under the the strain of
too many people coming what happened
with the University of Tennessee you
also had some fallout from your tweet
that got you temporarily suspended from
Twitter what's going on there that you
can talk about I can talk about
everything it's all over the university
Tennessee
sort of took them a little while but
they came out with a statement that my
speech is protected by the First
Amendment and you know not even worth
considering any sort of disciplinary
action and I was gratified to see that
they actually got the initial
announcement from my Dean said something
about an investigation and that's a lot
of people off and they actually heard a
lot from a lot of alumni who were very
angry about that and I think they
thought by sending that message out then
we're gonna please the alumni but it
turns out the Alumni at the University
of Tennessee are pretty big fans of free
speech and actually a lot of them read
insta pundit and they really got a
pretty substantial pushback but yeah I
was just talking to somebody today and
discovered it was much bigger even than
I had thought so um I think that played
a role but I also think you know we had
Tennessee has a greenlight rating from
fire the foundation for it about rights
and education that's the best you can do
and they are actually pretty proud of
that they brag about it when they
testified in the state legislature in
the state legislature seems to care
about free expression on campus so I
think that helped to what what makes
Tennessee University of Tennessee in
Knoxville which is a wonderful college
town I've I've I've driven by there
several times and spent a little bit of
time there what makes it unique about
among university campuses because they
hear you know fire doesn't give a lot of
green lights out and you know most of
the stories we hear and you certainly
write a lot about higher education is
that you know the lights are going out
all over academia what what makes
Tennessee
kind of more vital bastion of free
speech and free expression well you know
that's actually a good question and I
think it has to do with the politics of
the state of Tennessee I mean
Tennesseans are just fairly sensible
people and kind of you know I wouldn't
really call Tennesseans libertarians but
they're kind of small government don't
mess with me conservative types that
kind of overlap with libertarians a lot
and and they're just sort of very
well-grounded so I think I think that
the latest PC fads just don't have as
much traction here and I think that
makes a big difference
as a final point let me ask you you
talked earlier when you were talking
about libertarianism and you're kind of
version of libertarianism there is the
the big you know kind of if if you were
the king of the world of course you
would renounce your crown or make
everybody co-equal and we would have a
glorious utopia of utopias but in you
know short of that you go for the next
best thing
who are you gonna vote for in the
election have you made a decision and on
what grounds do you decide are you going
this way that way or possibly oh you
know to be honest it doesn't make any
difference in this place is as far from
a swing state as it could be it didn't
even make any difference in the
Republican primary so I don't know you
know I and actually I think you and I
were going back and forth on this on
Facebook earlier I'd really like to be
more enthusiastic about Gary Johnson but
I feel like in this really special year
for libertarians he might not have been
the best public face now maybe I'm wrong
he's probably better than libertarian
cads have done in the past you know but
tremendously much more so he may he may
appeal better to people who aren't
longtime libertarians than he does to
people who are and I may very well what
I vote for him if I can bring myself to
vote but of course it will make no
difference but actually maybe that's a
reason to vote for him because I can
vote for him and raise his totals and
help him out and have a completely clear
conscience because my vote won't make
the least bit of difference anyway are
you a you're certainly a never Hillary
are you also a never Trump er no here's
the argument for Trump that I
a little bit hard to dismiss and it's
not an argument based on Trump being
good it's just that everybody in the
establishment hates him
and I'm not saying vote for him to stick
a thumb in the eye of the establishment
though I got nothing against that in
general it's that a president Trump will
be very constrained by the media by
Congress even by Republicans in Congress
by sort of the deep state in the
bureaucracy whereas the Hillary email
scandal kind of and stuff really
indicates that Hillary just isn't
constrained by anybody so if you had to
choose between Trump and Hillary even if
they're equally bad and maybe even if
Trump is inherently worse
I think he's likely to do a lot less
damage because of that yeah that's and
you know one of the things that is
always hard to game with politics
particularly presidential politics is
it's an ecosystem question right if Bill
Clinton had managed to get a Clinton
care through in his first two years and
won a bigger majority in 1994 etc like
you know the 90s probably would have
been very different than managed the
unthinkable right which was to elect a
Republican Congress that actually kind
of acted in a small government fashion
at least in certain instances yeah
better that they've done better than the
Republican Congress that Obama elected
somehow ya know it's you know this is
the for me the libertarian optimism is
you know things can always get worse
right well we will leave it there we
have been talking with Glenn Reynolds
the University of Tennessee professor of
law who has recently suspended briefly
from Twitter read about it at insta
pundit calm he is the Internet's first
one and only insta pundit calm Glenn
thanks so much for talking to Reason
today thanks for having me four reasons
podcast I am Nick Gillespie please check
us out at iTunes SoundCloud we have RSS
feeds up the wazoo a go to recent com
podcast to subscribe please rate and
review everything that we do we like to
hear the feedback whether you're happy
sad or somewhere in between
thanks so much